the shooter who killed five people and
wounded 17 others at a Colorado Springs
lgbtq nightclub has been sentenced to
five consecutive life sentences in
prison 23-year-old Anderson Lee Aldrich
pleaded guilty yesterday to five counts
of murder and 46 counts of attempted
murder seven months after the attack in
court relatives and Friends of the
victims gave emotional statements about
their loved ones one wore a t-shirt
saying quote love always and never
forgotten earlier this month thousands
gathered at the first Pride Celebration
since the shooting the community created
a memorial that featured handwritten
notes of love and support the justice
department is considering whether pursue
Federal hate crime charges